donde nacen los Andes
Venezuela se jacta de ser el país donde
comienza la Cordillera continental más
larga del mundo
es como un parque de diversiones para
los ciclistas más aguerridos increíble
el paisaje
Daniel y sus socios trabajan en un
proyecto que nació en 2019 crear la
primera carrera de Ultra ciclismo en
Venezuela como en otros países de
América Latina las reglas son simples
los participantes aficionados o
profesionales deben recorrer 1000
kilómetros en total autonomía en un
máximo de cinco días
[Música]
el grupo hace antes un reconocimiento de
la ruta final de la futura carrera
Venezuela tiene muchísimos parques
nacionales Y muchísimas joyas naturales
para mostrarle a los venezolanos y a los
extranjeros que quieran venir a
disfrutarlas la verdad es que el
ciclismo de aventura es adaptable a casi
toda Venezuela
a raíz de la situación económica que
atraviesa el país el turismo está en
crisis desde hace una decena de años
pero en los últimos meses el sector ha
venido recuperándose por eso varios
patrocinadores privados ya están
apoyando el proyecto con la esperanza de
ayudar a desarrollar el ciclismo de
larga distancia creo que en Venezuela
hay muchos deportistas que bien lo que
necesitan es apoyo es generar equipo y
poder contar con el impulso para no solo
poderse dar a conocer sino para llevar a
cabo sus conocimientos y aprovechar lo
que tiene nuestro país para seguir
creciendo
en los últimos años el Ultra ciclismo ha
ido ganando popularidad en el Continente
en 2022 más de 200 personas algunas de
ellas provenientes de todo el mundo
participaron en carreras de larga
distancia en América Latina